you wait two years for a Mars mission
and then three come along at once there
are three separate spacecraft all
heading to Mars this year from the
United States China and the United Arab
Emirates but the middle of a pandemic
hardly seems like the best time to plan
a launch so why now one reason the teams
are all blasting off at about the same
time is that the next few months fall
within a perfect launch window right
about now Earth and Mars are lining up
in a way that makes it much easier than
usual to fly a vehicle from one planet
to the other this ideal alignment
happens only once every 2.2 years but
why 2020 and not 2018 or 2022 to answer
that question we need to take a look at
the journeys each of the three countries
has taken to get to this point for NASA
at the United States Space Agency this
is the fifth Rover to have sent to the
surface of the Red Planet the first
Sojourner landed in 1997 it was the size
of a microwave and made it just a
hundred meters across the surface the
latest rover Curiosity arrived on Mars
in 2012 and is still exploring the new
Rover is called perseverance it's almost
identical and designed to curiosity but
with one big difference it's designed to
drill and collect rock samples from the
Red Planet
that can hopefully one day be brought
back to earth and analyzed for signs of
ancient life so for NASA 2020 is the
culmination of decades of work and if
they don't launch now they'll face big
costs for delaying it's also their best
chance of being the first team to bring
Martian rock to earth soil China may be
behind the u.s. in terms of direct Mars
experience but they've had several space
successes in the last few years in 2013
they became the third country to land a
spacecraft on the moon and in 2019 the
first to land on the moon's far side
their lunar landers provide a template
for the rover they're sending to Mars as
part of the tn1 one
Mars however is a much longer trip and
potentially a much bigger challenge so
success would be a major triumph so
after years of slowly and methodically
building up their space program for
China the 2020 mission is the next
logical step towards demonstrating there
a major space power even a pandemic
won't get in the way of this important
goal finally the youngest space agency
joining the trip belongs to the United
Arab Emirates they started their space
program just six years ago with the aim
of sending their hope orbiter to map the
Martian weather it's a hugely ambitious
project that will be the first
interplanetary adventure of any Arab
nation many people hope it will open up
new areas of industry in the UAE and
inspire young people to become
scientists and for the UAE the 2020
launch window is their only opportunity
when the government set up the space
agency they gave them a deadline for
getting to Mars it had to be before the
country's 50th anniversary celebrations
in December 2021 so for the Emirati Mars
mission it's now or never
ultimately for all the teams it came
down to scheduling this is the moment
that the funding and the project
timelines and the planets all aligned
for these three countries their success
is by no means guaranteed Mars is a
notorious graveyard for failed
spacecraft and the ongoing pandemic will
undoubtedly create extra challenges to
overcome
but if perseverance tn1 and hope do make
it safely to Mars they could rewrite our
understanding of this enticing and
mysterious planet